let's start today with some of Joe
Biden's recent accomplishments you know
on the bonus show today we'll be talking
about President Joe Biden's first
presidential veto that was ordered I'm
not going to do that now because we have
a plan to talk about it a little bit
later but as the former president seems
to be closer and closer to a criminal
indictment it's important not to lose
sight of the fact that without
controversy without drama without
drawing with a Sharpie on a hurricane
map or asking about nuking Europe or a
hurricane or whatever the case may be
Joe Biden has accomplished a bunch of
little things none of which individually
are completely mind-blowing but it's a
lot of little very important things let
me know if you find this interesting let
me know if you find this informative
here are some examples the FCC
is going to release some additional
funds this week to support What's called
the affordable connectivity program and
this is a program it's part of the
bipartisan infrastructure law that was
passed under Joe Biden and it will
provide households that are eligible
with a thirty dollar credit towards the
cost of their internet service plan or a
75 dollar monthly credit for households
living on tribal land towards their
internet service and so the idea here is
get more people Broadband the effect you
might say well how many people will that
help it'll help a bunch of people and
then it will it's expected to get
Broadband to 16 million households that
don't currently have it that's like five
percent of the United States that's a
really big deal not explode it's not a
new health care plan but it is a program
with a a measurable benefit that will
get something that is increasingly a
requirement how do you increasingly how
do you exist in the world
um and and Avail yourself of all of the
normal amenities that many of us take
for granted if you don't have broadband
internet well this will get 16 million
households broadband internet that's a
great thing the Department of Health and
Human Services HHS is releasing half a
billion dollars in low-income home
energy assistance funds and the idea
here is help people cover home heating
costs we've had inflation Energy prices
are high the Biden Administration in
November announced the distribution of a
bunch of this money and it is now
happening and it's getting a little bit
of a bump to help people pay for heating
this is a great thing again it doesn't
solve the problem that groceries are
expensive it doesn't deal with stagnant
wages but now we've got credits towards
broadband and funds for home heating
that's a really great thing then we go
to prescription drugs there are new
details on which Medicare Part B drugs
now remember if you get access to the
bonus show we recently talked about what
are these drugs Medicare Part B drugs
are expensive drugs administered by
doctors if the prices of certain drugs
go up faster than inflation there are
going to be funds to subsidize the cost
of those drugs back down does this fix
the problem of health care prices or
prescription drug costs no but it's
going to identify drugs that will be
qualified for inflation rebates or
excessive price increases when the price
of these drugs goes up above and beyond
the cost of inflation and so people who
benefit from these funds will see the
prices of these drugs to them lowered in
some cases significantly that's another
really great thing now we go to the EPA
where this it's really broad spectrum
stuff we go to the EPA the EPA has taken
step forward in delivering clean water
uh particularly to disadvantaged
communities by proposing some new
standards national standards for
drinking water contamination levels and
what what amounts of certain elements
are allowed to be there in terms of pfas
substances this is expected to prevent
thousands of deaths and Reduce by tens
of thousands the number of illnesses
attributable to those types of water
contaminants is it perfect no does it
fix everybody's water everywhere no it
certainly doesn't but is it a good thing
with a measurable impact yes it is uh
and then a couple other small things a
Department of Transportation is
launching its Community electric vehicle
charging program oh but not everybody
can afford electric vehicles right but
as we go towards affordability hopefully
one of the big impediments is having
infrastructure to charge your car where
you live and or work and the Department
of Transportation is launching that
that's a program that was previously put
in place but it is now launching and
then the department of energy is moving
forward with 750 million dollars for
clean hydrogen research now I know there
are people who say David hydrogen fuel
is not the future well it might be uh it
might not be the future for vehicles but
maybe it is elsewhere it's certainly
something that should be researched and
that money is now being made available
these are all modest changes that will
have measurable positive impacts for in
some cases thousands or tens of
thousands or with some of these bigger
programs even millions of people quietly
accomplishing things couple different
thoughts number one is this interesting
to people is it interesting to hear
about some of these things that are
happening number two
is there a disconnect between those who
benefit from these programs and making
the connection that oh this is because
either of the inflation reduction act or
because of other programs I like that
maybe I am more satisfied with Joe
Biden's job performance than I thought
and what I mean by that is very often
people are asked do you approve or not
of the job that the president is doing
and oftentimes people say I do or I
don't and very often it's driven by
what's in the news oh the Afghanistan
withdrawal went well or it didn't go
well I approve or I disapprove when you
would think if people were more aware of
some of these programs if you're now
getting 30 bucks a month towards
broadband and they're starting to build
charging stations near where you live
and you're getting home heating
assistance and a Medicare Part B drug is
now being subsidized for you that's
tangible stuff but only if you know
about it might it influence your level
of satisfaction with the job that Joe
Biden is doing so that's another aspect
to this let me know your thoughts do you
want to regularly hear these sorts of
updates curious to hear what people
think